is John Krasinski an Eagles fan  absolutely not I'm offended you even  asked I'm a Patriots fan and I'm still  not over it is John Krasinski polish yes  I am that last name is not Irish and it  is not fake is John Krasinski married to  Jenna Fisher contrary to popular belief  no  um I'm actually married to Emily Blunt  and I feel pretty good about it is John  Krasinski related to Jane pretty sure  you mean Jane Krakowski and she's not  related to me though I get it I totally  get it  who is John Krasinski that's a great  question and a big question my identity  is something I'm still searching for so  thank you for giving me an anxiety  attack by even asking